donc j'étais à mon domicile ici à
l'extérieur et un moment donné donc
j'étais avec mon avec ma conjointe et à
un moment donné elle m'a alerté sur le
fait qu'il y avait des lueurs dans le
fond du jardin et je me suis quand je me
suis retourné tout de suite vu qu'il
s'agissait de flamme donc je me suis
précéde d'arriver là et puis j'ai vu que
effectivement la voiture était était en
train de brûler à ce moment-là il y a de
personnes qui qui sont sorties de la
propriété en escaladant le portail qui
en ont rejoint à 5 autres et qui sont
partis en courant dans
un peu dans toutes les directions j'ai
bien conscience que c'est ma c'est pas
ma personne qui est en cause mais plutôt
la fonction le symbole le symbole voilà
le symbole de la République
c'est comme ça que je me fais une une
part des choses quoi